people know me for either Bitcoin or
Andrew Tate at this point I think that's
like the only two reasons people know me
to be honest I think it's just because
they're seeing a woman talk about things
that men usually speak about I think
it's just that black and white cuz
usually it's nerds or if it is a woman
that's inter Tech she's usually got like
green hair and like GL I didn't want to
say where like I don't have green hair
you know piercings tattoos I don't have
any of that so I think it's just being
unique with everything that Andrew Tate
talks about I'm kind of like the only
woman that ended up agreeing with him
publicly at the start so I think just
being being different in a male
dominated space kind of gave me that
foot ahead